s'il vous plaît, le Nestlé est si confortable
que vous appartenez déjà à vous, nos gens parlent,
elle est passée
oh je suis désolé que
puis-je vous obtenir Wow hé vous savez que les
gens ont dit que c'est ce que je suis mais elle
dit ha ha
elle sait pourquoi
tant mais après DTF oh non elle a
dit classe s'il vous plaît ne semblez pas remèdes
tôt homo semblait une famille Majhi Tola
pourquoi je ne peux pas avoir une gaffe
si jamais vous obtenez je ne suis pas d'accord bien sûr
périchondre s '  il vous plait Nico quoi
right dream Akali Dal Steve quale a
elaqid evora empanada visas de poulet
produits sur contrôle déduit une fausse
paracosma pénalité de café située - Matt
Nauman Abbas technologie littéralement une
soupe de grenouille choc pâte d'audrianna sur un
moule Buffett quelle énergie de contrôle Ibaka
classe madame
Vijayan très simple
hé perroquet Reza Pahlavi l'intelligence la plus chaleureuse
bon de voir un autre frère ici
ah oui bien sûr il y a quelque chose qui ne va pas
là tu es oh bonjour
jusqu'à Amina et ça et tu es le
petit ami de Chris roses Chris était juste te
me dire comment il se sentait beaucoup plus à l'aise
avec ma présence ici c'est bien
non je déteste t'arracher ma chère
mais les coupes de vent posaient des questions sur toi
eh bien c'était agréable de te rencontrer Chris je
te dois des excuses
comme c'est impoli de ma part  pour attacher vos
affaires sans demander oh non c'est
cool j'étais juste confus eh bien je peux
vous assurer qu'il n'y avait pas d'affaire amusante
permettez-moi d'expliquer j'ai soulevé votre
téléphone portable pour effacer les adresses
et il s'est accidentellement défait ouais je préfère que de me
mêler de  en plus je l'ai
laissé comme ça à quel point c'est stupide de ma part c'est
bien je n'essayais pas de
vous
dénoncer, ouais oh ne vous inquiétez pas pour
ça je peux vous assurer que je ne réponds à
personne que
Jordan a décrit ce film comme  le
cauchemar ultime qu'un homme noir
aurait vivant en Amérique, c'est ainsi qu'il a
décrit ce qu'est ce film et l'
autre chose qu'il dirait à propos du
film est qu'il n'aurait jamais imaginé qu'il l'aurait presque
écrit comme une chose cathartique et il
n'aurait jamais imaginé que cela deviendrait  fait pour qu'il soit
toujours choqué même s'il dit toujours que
je suis choqué que mon cauchemar ait
été transformé en film vous les gars
venez en ville ouais il se dirige vers
le week-end puis-je voir votre permis
s'il vous plaît
il ne conduisait pas je l'ai fait  'demande pas qui
conduisait j'ai demandé à voir sa carte d'identité je pense
que ça a touché une corde sensible aux États-
Unis quand même parce que bien sûr c'était un
super film et il était très bien
commercialisé mais aussi évidemment à cause du
climat politique aux États-
Unis  en ce moment apparemment tout le
groupe de frères dans le Michigan cette autre
école nous sommes chauds tu n'as pas peur c'est l'
homme ne pouvait voir aucun frère d'argent ouais
désolé mec j'ai vécu en France pendant deux
ans j'ai vécu ici pendant un an au
lycée et  un an à l'université j'en parle
parce que notre méthode de réalisation
c'est vraiment c'est très français et très
européen et ce que c'est c'est une
méthode d'auteur nos réalisateurs ont beaucoup
plus de contrôle qu'ils n'en ont d'habitude
à Hollywood mais nous l'appliquons à la
comm  ercial films ce que nous allons vous donner les
deux clés Je ne sais pas ce que c'est
la raison la plus grande et la plus importante pour laquelle nous
faisons des films à petit budget est que nous pouvons prendre des
risques sur du matériel très très
inhabituel la raison pour laquelle tant de
films hollywoodiens se ressemblent  est leur façon dont
ils sont éclairés au vert, c'est qu'ils n'obtiennent un
feu vert que s'ils sont comparables à d'
autres films, donc par définition, cela rend
les films similaires, nous choisissons nos films
dans le sens opposé nouvel
engagement importé un autre si l'un de nous lit un
script et c'est ce qui s'est passé avec
sortir et nous entrons et nous disons que je n'ai
jamais rien lu de tel auparavant et
si c'est bien,
nous le rendons ouais des choses incroyables pour moi
quand les gens deviennent nerveux j'avais un
accord avec Paramount Pictures et  J'ai un
DVD sur mon bureau comme échantillon de réalisation un échantillon de
réalisation signifie regarder le film
si vous aimez ce film engagez le réalisateur
pour faire un autre film et je suis rentré chez
moi et j'ai regardé le film et le film était
Paranormal Activity à dix ans  avant
cela, je travaillais au Four Miramax pour
Harvey Weinstein et j'avais transmis le
projet Blair Witch et il m'a torturé
pendant dix ans, alors j'ai appelé le réalisateur
qui vivait à San Diego, j'ai dit de venir chez
moi et je les ai rencontrés et  J'ai dit que
je voulais vous séparer de vous sur
ce film et nous avons déchiré l'accord et
nous nous sommes associés et j'ai dit que je l'aiderais à le
faire entrer dans un théâtre et à ce moment-là
tout le monde avait transmis le film et cela
nous a pris trois ans  et nous l'avons finalement
mis au cinéma et même
sans traducteur, l'
Odyssée de trois ans prendrait environ une heure, donc sous
cette forme, cela pourrait prendre deux heures pour
vous raconter l'histoire, mais c'est la base
qui en est le début et c'est comme ça  c'est
arrivé Ted est venu vers moi je pensais que le
film était incroyable je n'avais aucune idée à quel
point il allait être brisé j'ai l'
impression qu'il y a trop de blancs qui
se font blesser
je voulais faire un film où les gens
crient juste au théâtre  tu sais
sors le [ __ ]  ng house
et je pense que j'ai réalisé que c'est un
être réel ici même avec un homme de génie comme toi
ouais j'aime les étoiles je vais croire
un enfant et ensuite l'hôte de cette
journée c'est tout ce qu'elle est morte sans côté
ouest c'est incroyable  Je suis excité ouais
alors qu'est-ce qu'ils savent en noir aujourd'hui
Jordan quand avez-vous commencé à écrire le
film quand le président Obama a été élu nous sommes
entrés dans cette ère que j'appelle le
mensonge post-racial nous avons un président noir
c'est fait nous l'avons dépassé  et beaucoup d'entre nous
savent que la race est très vivante et que le
racisme est très vivant et c'est ce
monstre qui mijotait
sous la surface du pays
pendant un certain temps et j'ai donc eu l'impression que ce
film était à l'origine destiné à résoudre
ce problème et à  lumière et de l'appeler
et vous savez maintenant que nous vivons à une
époque complètement différente et c'est juste que
c'est fascinant de voir comment le
voyage de ce film a conduit à ce moment où
maintenant j'ai l'impression que c'est plus
pertinent que jamais c'est  une excellente réponse
t  voilà donc vous venez de la
ville ouais il y a des coupures pour le
week-end puis-je voir votre permis s'il vous plaît
il ne conduisait pas je n'ai pas demandé qui
conduisait j'ai demandé à voir sa carte d'identité
Daniel comment vous êtes-vous impliqué dans le
projet et qu'en est-il du projet qui
vous intéressait, cela a vraiment résonné en
moi, c'était à quoi ressemble le racisme parce que
c'est comme si c'était une sorte de paranoïa quand
vous êtes dans une pièce pour les blancs
et que vous êtes comme mmm signe, je ne le fais pas
sais ce qui ne va pas personne ne dit quoi que ce soit
elmo est debout comment ça fait d'être je ne suis pas
une fille blanche ceux-là je suis si fier je voulais
faire quelque chose de plus euh je ne sais pas
que ça énerverait un peu les gens
et  en fait, faire parler les gens étaient
ravis de vous avoir ici pour ça
ouais se réunir
- quelque chose peut être dans les films d'horreur
il y a toujours de la merde à avoir
peur de pourquoi l'aspect psychologique de
celui-ci je suis un grand fan d'horreur et je  l'impression que
tous les grands films d'horreur ont
quelque chose à dire ils ont une vraie horreur
dont ils parlaient et j'avais l'impression que la
question du racisme et de la psychologie du
racisme avait été ignorée dans ce genre
et j'ai l'impression que c'est
censé combler une lacune, il est
censé combler cette pièce manquante du
conversation à travers l'histoire et le
divertissement j'ai l'impression que nous négligeons souvent l'
un des moyens les plus puissants de
communiquer et en ce moment j'ai l'impression
que la façon dont nous parlons de race dans ce
pays est cassée et vous savez que je ne sais pas
peut-être que ça va [ __ ] la merde  dans le
mauvais sens je ne sais pas mais j'ai l'
impression que l'art et la communication sont comme
ça c'est le seul outil que nous avons
contre les vraies horreurs du monde
qui est la violence donc j'espère
que c'est  une expérience inclusive et
j'espère que c'est quelque chose qui inspire les
gens à juste parler pour voir ces
frères gémir
yo désolé mec
yo les noirs étaient des
fans de films d'horreur très fidèles nous aimerions crier ce que les gens
devraient faire à l'écran surtout quand
ils sont  pas toi  savent qu'ils ne le font pas, ils
ne le font pas au fil du temps, nous avons été à notre
manière dans cet espace sombre en
criant sur cet écran et nous ne pouvons pas
affecter les [ __ ] de conneries qui se
passent de l'autre côté, alors  Dee
quand vous l'ajoutez à regarder les nouvelles
aujourd'hui comme si j'y pensais,
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde a l'impression d'
être là en ce moment, nous avons également
besoin en ce moment de choses qui sont en brique qui
vont nous rassembler comme  les gens alors
j'espère que ce film crée
une sorte de catharsis créative collective d'
une manière une marque déposée CCC comme votre
film laser merci beaucoup les
gars  faire du campus
un semi devient certains d'entre eux les jeunes
familles peuvent trouver une icône cinq feront-
ils avec le Victoria nous ne voyons que
spasmatiquement le week-end ouais Meccano a mis en place
un détecteur amici di stéfano unos cuantos
anos de l'eau de cosas del voto de hacer
los  L'esto activé de LaVon Hayes Sakya
P  andita promotion America demoscene in30
même géométrie sévérité femme Alva Tony
Botti très proche de l'équipe de
crétins Samantha Morgan 34 histoire postale jomkwan elle
cool n'est-il pas possible que cette
guitare acoustique appréciative oh oh non non
[Applaudissements]
adorable